Hello, everyone! A lot of people have requested this game, so here it is.
I don't know if it's really the last queen sacrifice of 2017, but until I'm proven wrong, I'm just gonna go with it.
From 31st of December to 3rd of January,
Wei Yi, the Chinese Grandmaster, is playing against the number one Czech Grandmaster, David Navara.
It's a chess match. It's a four game chess match, and the winner of this match will be given
$20,000. The loser will also get $10,000. So it's not a bad deal. Even if you lose you get $10,000.
The match is being played in Yancheng in China, and so far
they've already played three games; today was the third game. The result is one and a half each, and tomorrow is the final game.
If tomorrow will be a draw, then they will go into tiebreaks.
But I will put the details of the match in the description below, so you can check it out.
So, let's see this game. Wei Yi has the white pieces and it's really a wild game. We have
e4 and c6 by Navara,
for all you
Caro-Kann enthusiasts.
d4, d5, and e5; the advance variation of the Caro-Kann. Bishop to f5, and here,
I thought that someone of Wei Yi style would definitely go for g4 or something like g4;
the Bayonet Attack, but
in fact he goes for knight do d2.
We have e6 and knight to b3. It's an interesting idea.
I don't think I've ever seen a Caro-Kann being handled this way. The knight
will be very useful here as you'll see in the game. Knight to d7, we have Knight to f3,
a6 now, bishop to e2, and c5, and
here c3 was played, h6, and now d captures on c5 by Wei Yi.
And bishop captures on c5, and this is the idea behind this knight to b3 opening.
If you play Knight captures on c5 here if you don't want to give up the bishop pair
Then Knight can come Knight F to d4 and after Bishop moves to g6 white and castle and it's a wonderful position for white
White is already threatening f4 f5 to break open the position the black king is still stuck in the middle
If black captures on b3 you can even play a ache after some b3 and then you get an open a file for your rook
So it's quite a dangerous
so after D captures on c5
Navara plays Bishop captures on c5 we have Knight captures on c5 sorry about that
And knife captures on c5 and Bishop to e3 now attacking the knight on c5
rook to c8 and
Hear ye castles. We have Knight to e7
Knights to d4 and here no Bishop to g6 or anything like that simply castles
never our doesn't mind if we captures the Bishop on f5 simply Knight captures and f5 will come and
That night will be pretty much stuck there on f5 I mean it's a great square for the Black Knight for the dark knight
Only way white will be able to take it away is either by capturing your Buddha light square Bishop or by pushing g4
So we have a for
Bishop to h7 and a5 now
Knight to c6
We have Knight captures rook captures as d5 pawn was attacked and Bishop to d4 and
Namara plays Queen to g5 bringing the Queen into the attack
and rook to a3 a more
Safe for a safer approach would be something like f3 okay
This is a bit counterintuitive you do block your Queen and Bishop put the f3 pawn
But then again you deny the night it is very important efore square
But okay way he goes for rook to a3
Probably where ideas of playing something like c3 and rook to g3 to bring the rock into the attack
Navarro plays Queen to a5 now he
Brings more pressure to the d3 square now to join the knight can jump to d3
before in the night, but Knight can come to d3 as we said and the g4
Attacking the Queen Queen to g6 and now f4 way is now threatening f5
The Queen will be attacked after capture on f5
We will simply capture the Nikon d3s it will no longer be defended
So Queen to b4 not allowing a fight with tempo
And we have Bishop to f3 attacking the Queen and here navara goes for it
He plays Queen captures on f4 and he allows this
it seems like a
Winning move for white Bishop captures undies, but actually navara went for this on purpose
He captures on b5 now given up the queen
We have rook captures Queen on f4 and the Knight captures on f4 so given up the Queen for a bishop and the rook
Doesn't really
Give you
like
Equality in material sense, but his position is quite quite good
And here something like rook to b3 may be preparing a move like b5 would be okay for white
but wait played Bishop to e3 he attacked the night and if an f4
Knight the d3 now the knight is protected by the bishop on and on h7
The threat is to capture d5 pawn and you really don't have a way of
Defending that point you can only play Bishop back to d4 and this is what we played so basically. He just wasted a move
That's not really something you want to do after like just sacrificed his Queen
rook to e8 and now with a double attack on the pawn and Queen to f3 now if you capture d5 pawn
We captures the d5 pawn noir goes for it Knight captures on e5 we have Queen captures on d5 and now Knight captures on g4
Grabbing another pawn, and this is this could have been a very important pawn in defending the white king
It will be hard to solidify. Okay could play h3 but black could always just break open the position
rook to a
One-way he has to bring this rook back into the game
We have worked to g6 now. This rook to g6 comes with a threat of eternai to f6 check or night
III check picking out the Queen so we place queen capture some b7
grabbing that point in getting the Queen out of the way, and we had night the e3 check and
Here King 2 f2 is actually the only good move if you play something like King to h1
then this very annoying group to g4 comes and
Now there's a threat of Bishop to g4
Checking the King and also attacking the Queen
But you can't really move the Queen if you move the Queen then Bishop to b4 will be checkmate
So you don't really have any options here if you capture for example Bishop 3 4 check Queen captures rook captures
It's 2 rooks the rook and the bishop easily winning position for black so after this night - III
king - f2 was played
Now we have Knight to g4 check King back to g1 and out Knight to e5 check
And here Navarre plus, or ye played King to f1 and this was it's not the losing move
But it definitely gives Navarro more than he should have a better move here is actually King - h1 the exact same move
I just said that that didn't work
But it didn't work when the black when the dark night was an e3 now that it's an e5 it actually works
Now rook to g4 doesn't work because simply rook to e1
The rook is now guarding d4 square when tonight was an e3 the rook couldn't guard e4 square
So here after something like f6 okay you do defend tonight, but white is white is winning here
He can black doesn't really have a threat or I can simply push be five a-six a-seven a-eight
But after this Knight to e5 check
King to f1 by Navarro by way
we had rook to f6 check King to g2 and now rook back to g6 check and
Again navara has the option of blinking - h1 but he plays King to f1 and we have rook to g5 here
bishop characters on e5 and now Bishop to d3 check King to f2 rook captures Bishop
We have worked to d1 and this rook to d1 is actually the losing move for way
But you'll see why the idea
The idea for way here is to play Queen to c8 check
And I only after King moves to h7 only then move the rook but - you'll see why
after rook to d1
And noir played rook to e2 with check we have King to f3 in our rope to f5 check King to g4
H5 check we have king the King to h4 and now rook to e4 check and in this position we resigned to the game
But as you can see in this position
There would there wouldn't have been a rook to f5 check if Queen to CH check was played first before rope to d1
Then rook couldn't come to five and none of this would actually work for black
It would probably be some sort of a draw. I mean the game would continue, but there would be no immediate win for Davin navara
But okay the she played rook to d1 so King to g4 h5 check
King to h4 rook to e4 check in this position where you resign to the game? What would follow is something like King to g3
rook to e3 check and now
It depends really if you play something like King to g2 then simply Bishop three four check picks up the Queen
Queen captures rook captures, and it's two rooks against the two rooks against the rook
also something young Gustavson often says
His favorite kind of endgame is the one where he has a rock and his opponent doesn't
But after rook to e3 check instead of King g2 you could also play something like King to h4
But then comes g5 you have to capture on h5 King captures on h5
Bishop to e2 check King to h6 and rook to h3 this is checkmate
so a very nice game by Davi navara a very brave game the Queen sacrifice wasn't exactly crushing but
It was it was an active game, and he managed to pull it off
We didn't didn't
maneuver with the King the way he should have but
You know it's always hard when it's an open position and your king is running loose
So that's the game I do. Hope you enjoyed it if you
Have any other
Games featuring an Ice Queen sacrifice between grandmasters played on the 31st of December do share in the comments
but until then this is the last Queen sacrifice of
As usual you can check to my previous videos here think all for watching, and I will see you soon